[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 en pleine
inflation de nombreux Français peine à
boucler les fins de mois une difficulté
redondante notamment depuis la crise de
covid au sein de la Croix-Rouge
française des Yvelines peut-on craindre
une augmentation des bénéficiaires
est-ce déjà le cas et qu'elles sont les
nouveaux besoins pour en parler avec
nous je reçois aujourd'hui Jean-Michel
Lauzat directeur du territorial pardon
de l'action sociale à la Croix-Rouge des
Yvelines bonjour bonjour alors la Croix
Rouge est donc présente dans les
Yvelines pour venir en aide au public
précaire quels sont vos missions et
actions tout au long de l'année
alors les missions sont nombreuses bien
entendu elle concerne essentiellement
aller vers les bénéficiaires qui sont
dans le plus grand besoin mais il y a
aussi un autre volet qui un volet
secourisme donc pour couvrir des
événements ou porter secours lorsqu'il y
a un événement particulier traumatisant
donc voilà donc il y a sur le territoire
1800 bénévoles qui sont répartis sur 16
unités locales donc des points de
proximité et donc dans chacune de ces
unités locales il y a des activités qui
sont
réalisées en fait en complémentarité
avec les autres associations locales
l'idée étant de ne pas multiplier les
offres et plutôt des diversifier donc
c'est justement essentiel de travailler
ensemble main dans la main sur les avec
les différentes associations du
territoire absolument c'est d'autant
plus d'essentiel que
la précarité augmente les besoins
augmentent et il faut vraiment jouer
désormais la complémentarité et pas la
concurrence donc on est organisé
structuré avec le département avec la
lecture pour qu'il y ait une
coordination une animation du territoire
vous l'avez évoqué du coup d'autres
associations sont réputées pour
organiser des collectes de dons
alimentaires vous le faites également
plusieurs fois dans l'année on peut vous
croiser ou vous rencontrer à l'entrée
des supermarchés avec une liste de
produits essentiels de quel produit par
le ton oui alors c'est un point très
important puisque même si aujourd'hui en
France personne ne meurt de faim il y a
des besoins de besoins qui sont criants
de plus importants la pauvreté augmente
et du coup la Croix-Rouge récupère des
denrées pardon ou à la banque
alimentaire ou en faisant des collectes
sur des lieux spécifiques et donc du
coup on est sollicite finalement des
dons pour pouvoir les redistribuer
ensuite dans des épiceries sociales pour
que ça aille directement au plus
nécessiteux en fait on parle donc
d'alimentation mais également de
produits d'hygiène et pour bébé on
pourrait penser que l'alimentaire est
plus important en quoi les produits
d'hygiène sont essentiels pour les
personnes en situation de précarité
alors
c'est essentiel parce que ça coûte très
très cher c'est très très cher les gens
les comprennent ont des habitudes et ce
sera fait partie des produits finalement
qui sont difficiles à collecter et donc
ça fait deux on a de plus en plus besoin
d'acheter ces produits là pour pouvoir
les redistribuer donc
comme je disais tout à l'heure il y a
énormément d'associations qui donnent à
manger
les espaces Parents Bébé par exemple il
y en a beaucoup moins et c'est un lieu
où privilégié ou effectivement on peut
prendre attention à la fois des enfants
mais surtout des mamans la période covid
a déjà eu un impact sur le sur le
porte-monnaie des Français pendant cette
période on a eu également plus de
bénéficiaires une évolution enfin une
augmentation par nos des bénéficiaires
maintenant c'est l'inflation qui vient
bouleverser le quotidien des Français
est-ce que vous avez déjà noté une
augmentation des bénéficiaires depuis le
début de l'inflation alors
oui évidemment évidemment c'est
indéniable on le note tous moi la
Croix-Rouge a un point de particularité
quand même par rapport aux autres
associations c'est que nous souhaitons
travailler dans un mode de réinsertion
des personnes donc on nous travaillons
en liaison directe avec les travailleurs
sociaux avec les assistantes sociales et
il y a un échange une discussion sur le
parcours de vie sur comment s'organise
avec les assistantes sociales avec les
associations pour que la personne peut à
peu se réinsère et finalement sorte par
le haut du coup on a un filtre la Croix
Rouge ne prend pas on dire en direct un
gros flux de demande alors ils nous
viennent et on les on les réoriente peu
à peu donc du coup on prend moins
peut-être de front cet accroissement de
personnes à la rue est-ce que la
conclusion c'est aussi que les citoyens
font moins de moins de dons envers les
associations justement ça ça sans doute
même si même si lorsque il y a eu la
période pour l'Ukraine il y a eu un
afflux important de solidarité mais au
quotidien c'est vrai que les citoyens et
de plus en plus sollicités et que
finalement les dons sont sa menuisent un
peu au sein de la Croix-Rouge justement
quels sont les besoins actuels pour
venir en aide aux bénéficiaires à ceux
que vous vous suivez que vous aidez
alors comme je dis je disais tout à
l'heure on est besoin de plus en plus
d'acheter des dents et alimentaires et
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
très très structurant donc on a besoin
de fonds pour cela l'ensemble des fonds
bien sûr sont redistribués pour dans
l'ordre d'activité pour les
bénéficiaires mais oui je dirais je
dirais surtout de l'alimenter
aujourd'hui et vous organisez également
des des maraude commence à organiser ces
maraudes à quoi servent-elles ah alors
les maraude les maraudes c'est porter
secours pendant la nuit il y a des
personnes qui sont dans la rue alors
elles sont dans la rue parce qu'elles
ont pas trouvé de lieu où dormir puisque
le matin ou pendant toute la journée
elles peuvent appeler le 115 pour
solliciter un hébergement pendant la
nuit ou de l'aide et en fait les maux de
se mettent en action dans l'après-midi
et pendant toute la nuit pour porter
secours pour aller rencontrer ces
personnes qui se sont manifestées et qui
ont dit j'ai besoin de quelque chose
donc les maraudeurs vont à l'encontre à
la rencontre de ces personnes là et puis
bien entendu malheureusement dans chaque
ville on sait qu'il y a des lieux
particuliers privilégiés où il y a les
ou les personnes se mettent et donc
entre deux points de rendez-vous on va
les voir et on essaie de leur porter
secours un dispositif que vous avez mis
en place c'est le vesti boutique quelles
sont les objectifs du l'esthétique alors
le vestiboutique
aujourd'hui il y a une grande mode sur
tout ce qui est vêtements vintage etc
etc la Croix-Rouge a été sans doute
précurseur en la matière puisque ça fait
des années qu'on collecte des vêtements
on les trie et on les on les revend on
les revend alors à des bénéficiaires à
des prix modiques bien entendu mais
aussi à toute personne des Yvelines ou
française ou autre ces espaces sont
ouverts et à chaque fois que vous allez
acheter quelque chose un vêtement
à un prix finalement très très
raisonnable vous faites un don à la
Croix-Rouge qui permet cette fois-ci de
réinvestir dans des denrées alimentaires
dont on parlait tout à l'heure ce qui
est intéressant du coup c'est qu'on on
s'inscrit finalement dans cette seconde
main dans du développement durable en
évitant cette fast fashion qui est
beaucoup critiqué en ce moment et en
même temps on aide une association donc
finalement il faudrait qu'un peu plus de
citoyens s'intéressent à ce mode d'achat
oui et puis il faut aussi sans doute que
l'on en fasse un peu plus la promotion
alors bien sûr on est en concurrence
directe par rapport à d'autres sociétés
qui font dol qui gagne de l'argent avec
ça nous on va le réinvestir mais c'est
important qu'effectivement tous on sache
que on peut passer on peut passer la
porte de la Croix Rouge et venir faire
un don finalement sous cette forme alors
en achetant quelque chose ou en faisant
un don tout court puisque ça c'est
effectivement ça sera toujours quelque
chose qui sera réinvesti dans des
actions locales et on peut également
donner nos vêtements
on peut donner nos vêtements absolument
et on a beaucoup de personnes qui
effectivement viennent dans une dans une
unité locale pardon et qui font des dons
et donc du coup c'est c'est bon là il y
a de la même façon ils sont triés et
puis une partie va partir dans un
troisième cycle et puis une seconde va
la première la nominale va être disposé
dans nos boutiques pour pour
bénéficiaires et nos et nos clients on a
beaucoup parlé de l'aide alimentaire et
de l'aide vestimentaire du coup quels
sont les autres accompagnements et être
que vous proposez au sein de la
Croix-Rouge alors la Croix-Rouge
accompagne sur toute forme d'action par
exemple
l'enseignement du français le soutien
scolaire la domiciliation la
domiciliation étant la capacité de se
faire envoyer le courrier à la
Croix-Rouge parce qu'on est dans la rue
et qu'on n'a pas de décembre domicile
fixe et une adresse c'est fondamentale
pour pouvoir se réinsérer donc voilà
deux types de type d'exemple de
d'actions que l'on fait elles sont très
très nombreuses et du coup c'est c'est
un vrai bonheur pour un bénévole parce
que il peut basculer d'une activité à
l'autre et finalement voir de nombreuses
facettes de comment investir son temps
pour les autres justement en parlant de
bénévoles vous êtes à la recherche de
bénévoles donc pour vos actions sociales
mais également pour les JO p2024 qu'elle
serait les actions les missions pardon
de des bénévoles pour les JO P 2024
alors petit focus sur les Jeux
Olympiques
il va y avoir évidemment une grande
grande manifestation et énormément de
population énormément de sportifs et
bien entendu il va falloir porter
secours au public et puis accompagner
les sportifs donc pour chaque site
olympique des associations ont été
nommées et en fait ça se régule c'est à
dire qu'il y a vraiment des actions pour
tous et il y a un commun dénominateur
c'est que nous sommes en manque de
secouriste et donc du coup on recherche
des secouristes qui seraient prêts à
s'investir pendant les JO c'est une
façon aussi d'y participer ils seront
formés et d'ici là ils seront formés ils
auront été un peu sur le terrain pour
pratiquer et du coup ils seront
opérationnels pour les Jeux Olympiques
donc on a pas besoin d'avoir des bases
finalement de secourisme pour pour
pouvoir vous rejoindre justement pour
CGP absolument merci beaucoup
Jean-Michel Lausanne d'avoir été avec
nous sur sensation on peut également
faire des dons sur le sur le site de la
Croix-Rouge très rapidement à quoi
servent ces dons c'est également pour
les vêtements pour l'alimentaire alors
pas pour les vêtements mais pour
l'alimenter et pour l'engagement sur
toutes les actions auprès des auprès des
des plus démunis l'un des sites du coup
également pour avoir plus d'informations
c'est le site Yvelines Croates rouges.fr
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
merci sur sensation et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]